Linux is by far the most popular
operating system of choice for
web servers on the Internet today.
Some estimates say 80% of
public Internet servers
are running some flavor of Linux.
So what exactly is Linux?
Linux is an operating system
similar to Microsoft Windows or
Apple OS X,
which you might be more familiar with.
The biggest difference with
Linux though is it's free.
Now, when I say free,
you may be thinking of money, and
that's not necessarily the case.
You may have heard the phrases,
free as in beer and free as in speech.
It's quite popular within
the open source community.
Let's discuss what
each of these means and
how they apply to
the Linux operating system.